okay I don't know how many of you all
noticed this or what it actually means
but note that the first time Apple ever
showed the Vision Pro headset to the
world in real life they used this shot
this sort of stabilized orbiting short
shot rotating around ahead and then
looking through the headset inside and I
started seeing it bubbling up on Twitter
but you might have caught that it's
actually a reference to this shot in
Ready Player One
he gave us a place to go
a place called
The Oasis
it's basically the exact same shot what
is it supposed to mean that they're
referencing that movie like ready player
one is actually a pretty dystopian movie
where right after that scene they
explain how people got way too into the
virtual world to the point where they
were literally neglecting their kids and
correlating it too much with real life
so maybe it's a warning maybe it's a
coincidence
it's probably not a coincidence